I didn't tell you about the prophecy  just so that you'd break up with Eve  although I do think you're doing the  right thing and I'm here to support you  in any way I can  thank you well it must have been hard  what's that oh the break-up you know how  did it go good good  now we're adopting a cat and looking at  houses in Encino oh you changed your  mind  no I'm certainly breaking up with Eve is  the right thing to do yes but is it what  you want  what I want is irrelevant I need to  break up with her in order to restore  things back to the way they were and you  know save humanity it's just gonna be a  bit more difficult than our first  thought vessel  [Music]  [Music]